when you see this you don't imagine that
you're hearing this or when this
dragonfly floats by on the big screen
you aren't imagining this behind the
scenes Foley art is one of those unseen
jobs in Hollywood making our experience
at the movies feel real and immersive
take a look at ten of the most
surprising ways Foley artists have
created sounds you can't exactly punch a
real person so Foley artist Sean Brennan
will start by punching his bare hands
punches involve a lot of sound layering
he will add gloves to beef it up and
then take it a step further by punching
an old rolled-up phonebook wrapped in
duct tape for a more violent and gory
fight scene he needed something more
exaggerated and found that punching raw
meat worked well Shawn needed a cut that
best imitated the texture of a human
cheek and could also lie perfectly flat
on his palm the answer a one pound piece
of raw flank steak Foley artists often
need to cover animals as well as humans
one of the most common animals that they
encounter is horses
thanks to Monty Python and the Holy
Grail coconut shells have become closely
associated with horse galloping fully
artist Marco Costanzo might pull out a
pair of plastic coconut shells but they
aren't always effective for instance the
sound of the shells comes out if you are
doing the sounds for a horse running on
cobblestone but for a movie like true
grit where the horses mostly run dirt
and grass the sound of the shells
wouldn't resonate at all the low-end
thud most associated with for slopes
would come out better with a pair of
rocks
when a horse is moving you won't just
hear the hooves so you'll have to layer
in a few other sounds as well if you
need some tail flicks in there waving
around shredded rope does it good
imitation of a horse's tail when
creating the sound of an animal eating
the first thing you need to figure out
is if the food is wet or dry making the
sound of a horse eating is also a
particular challenge they typically eat
dry food which is easy they also have
snouts however which can complicate how
the sound gets made to account for the
snout Marco makes a cavern by cuffing
his hands over his mouth while chewing
this creates a cavity of sound for
another take of a scene he had to
pretend to be a horse eating out of a
bucket now he couldn't actually stick
his head into a bucket
he found that chewing while putting his
head between the legs of a stool created
the exact echo he was searching for
Foley artist Matt Davies has worked on
several horror films a few of them
called for the sounds of falling
intestines so he's successfully
experimented with raw chicken not only
does the chicken's texture give just the
right sound but the more you handle this
meat the warmer and slimy er it gets
making it perfect for multiple takes but
raw chicken isn't always the cleanest
product for Foley artists to utilize so
when working on the horror movie VHS 2
he found he could get the same effect
squeezing and squishing chocolate
pudding and latex hoses for intestinal
movement
remember this dragonfly from the opening
of men and black the camera gets up
close to the insect and follows it
around so the viewer needs to be able to
hear all of the buzzing when marco is
tasked with recreating this sound he
first thought about playing around with
different types of paper he tried
putting a card in a bicycle spoke and
then spinning the wheel around however
it was mostly the sound of the metal
spoke that came through the Dragonfly
needed to sound organic he eventually
found it what worked best was a handheld
fan with this device he could more
easily account for the insects variation
in movement by sticking his finger on
the blade but there was no metal after
effect Shawn Brennan works on a lot of
action movies which means he's needed to
create the sounds of an arleigh head
stomp and smash for a head crack you
need a bone crunching effect to get the
sound of a skull being crushed ideally
the object will provide a crunch and a
smush while celery is usually great for
a bone crack it sounds too dry Shawn
said that on one occasion they had just
stocked the kitchen with apples for
snacking when a Foley mixer suggested
trying one out so he took a few pieces
of the fruit and stomped on them with
his foot the apple not only cracks when
you stomp on it but it also gives you
that squishy element which you wouldn't
get from drier fruit or veggies
many swords and movies have a ringing
quality to them but it is difficult to
make this sound with a real sword
because not only would you get the
ringing sound but you would also get an
unpleasant scraping noise so how do you
get the ringing without the scraping for
starters Matt Davies knew he still
needed to use a metal object and he
landed on a metal shelf support however
it couldn't make the desired sound on
its own so he took a cello bow and bowed
the side of the metal then he
immediately waved it around in the air
you can hear what Matt describes as a
magical quality Foley artists don
Lunsford and alicia's stevenson worked
on bumblebee and created many of the
sounds of the adorable transformers
character while the sounds of
transforming between car and autobot
were done digitally the character still
moved around and interacted with the
world a lot which required some clever
Foley work for the shot where bumblebee
sits on a couch and then breaks it they
had to get both the sound of the massive
creature squashing the couch and the
couch itself collapsing to get an object
both heavy enough to capture bumble bees
size as well as his metal features
elisha banged an old lawnmower against a
car door then on a separate track dawn
hit a car seat cushion with her hands
sometimes Marco needs to mimic the
vocals of certain animals when a digital
library just doesn't cut it usually he
would use his mouth but for a mouse
squeaking and a small bird chirping he
found that it was better to let some
objects do the talking so he used this
wooden chair leg marco found that if he
took the wooden leg and attached a
squeaking knob to it he could create the
sounds of both a bird and a mouse by
just turning it he will do fast in small
turns for the mouse and for the bird
each turn will go on a little longer
when that had to work on something like
the zombies in VHS - it wasn't the
fleshy chewing sounds that were the
problem the real challenge came when
imitating these creatures vocally
there's a huge history of zombie noises
to draw on however Matt has found that
some of the classic zombie sounds just
consist of a lot of grunting
which feels less scary today he found a
lot of sounds and more modern zombie
features come closer to how gory their
noises would be in reality so he decided
to make the sounds more guttural and
Flemmi and he found the result to be
much scarier thanks for watching if you
like learning about how sounds are made
for movies subscribe for many more
videos just like this one and let us
know what other Foley sounds you'd like
to see in action in the comments